greetings from podcast Ville its
[ __ ] Christmas Eve but guess
what it's still Monday and you gotta get
your party [ __ ] started now the
church what's happening now is brought
to you by hello to chic calm are you
sick and tired of your ass smelling like
ten dead billy goats it's time for a
portable bidet go - hello - she calm
they have portable days starting at $69
and they come with hot water but I mean
listen your [ __ ] could be brand new
you understand me you're single you got
nothing going on it's not your breath
it's not your haircut maybe it's a sniff
of your whiff you follow me it's time to
wash that muffler go - hello - she calm
right now and put in muffler and get 10%
off your order all right that's how I
work it's easy and it can't amount the
load whatever the [ __ ] the word is
number to bold season is here it's time
to get in on the action with my bookie
don't be that guy ruin interest on your
relatives or friends sitting around
watching the game not this year with
that when there's a record 41 bowl games
to bet on 41 bowl games including the
national championship on January 7th
this is a beautiful time of the year if
you want to make some money
you got the ballgames you got NFL
playoffs you got basketball do me a
favor
join my bookie and they offer you 50%
deposit bonus to make sure you have a
nice bankroll for both season use promo
code Church when you deposit to activate
the offer that means if you put in a
hundred boom they'll put in 50 but you
gotta use promo code Church CH you are
CH and that's ed my bookie and I
recommend them you play you win you get
paid take that [ __ ] muley thank you
thank you very much for [ __ ] hanging
in there with us we had to take a week
off I was in New York after week thank
you very much for appreciating the
Ralphie May podcast we put it up for a
reason I put it up for various reasons
it's a funny [ __ ] podcast plus it
makes us remember that you know one
they a woman that they got gonna take
nobody for granted but how the [ __ ]
high note my man Rick Ramos is here from
the watch this podcast Rick Ramos I feel
he is one of the most talented [ __ ]
people I know when it comes to movies
directors why they did it the second ad
that [ __ ] you know you don't want to put
a [ __ ] thank god this guy don't snort
coke you put me in strong put a movie on
with him you're done he'll tell you who
bought the table why and they bought it
downtown but uh we're good we're here to
talk about the ten movies you should
watch over the holidays I'm not talking
about [ __ ] like you know they're
gonna watch The Godfather
these are obscure films I want to hate
you and this is [ __ ] I've been thinking
about lately
I'm not guess what out of ten I wrote
down I'm probably gonna watch one oh I
have no time I forgot the kids got no
[ __ ] school the next one yeah I mean
what Barry no she's gonna be running you
wild your best bed just to take her to
the park and run her go on her Runner
and then obviously [ __ ] not there's a
rule at the house yeah next week I gotta
get into the park Monday by night yeah
so Monday my wife has I gotta do
something in the morning I'm doing a
podcast then Christmas Day 9 o'clock
we're getting gifts let's get out and
run it the monkey bars
yeah those monkey bars odd she does that
swing for her [ __ ] core mmm-hmm she
runs she chases she's always makes
friends with the ugliest kid at the park
and next you know they're running
together it's they're chasing each other
she comes home scratching what am I
gonna do a weird smile a next well what
am I gonna do sometimes I smile a hand
it smells like dead bodies coming to
sweat and I come chasing I tell my wife
come and shampoo ad it smells terrible
but you got to get them going loose dog
I saw it in New York fearfully our
vacation was great you know it was a cut
a little short yeah
but the vacation was great we got to go
look we did two mistakes we stand in New
Jersey mm-hmm I did it because of the
ferry ride yes it's a ferry ride for us
before she's Jacque Cousteau
yeah the waves ahead she thinks it's the
ocean yeah [ __ ] nuts and River you see a
hand floating you know
I'm looking for I kept a look at that on
well there's no I'm daddy I'm telling
you there's an arm there they threw a
Puerto Rican off this [ __ ] bracelet
right
yeah 365 days a year they 200 people
gotta go a year oh yeah George
Washington Bridge really I think yeah
people are losing it man it's people I
walk up to that bridge you don't know
how many times I looked over that
bridges right [ __ ] it
that's a beautiful jump worth looking
happily you break four ribs or something
no even that's the best thing that could
happen you jump off the George
Washington Bridge a few if it if you die
in it's over and there's nothing else to
be worried about and but the little boy
jump off the bridge inland yeah they've
done they've done a couple break their
legs break their back you know it don't
work out like you think it's going to
work out and then you you're suffering
for the rest of what a little bit of
life you got before it did it Rambo did
it yeah no y'all jumped off cliffs and
they [ __ ] live they ran ran and ran
after that every three and a half days
someone does it I told you see three and
a half days in 2015 let's see if I can
find an actual number [ __ ] people are
miserable people are [ __ ] up it's a
hard world out there you know when
you're working a job and your boss is
coming down on you about every goddamn
thing being a prick about it you know
you're on the toilet if you're on the
ferry you might catch a body hell yeah
well those suicides go right by so this
is why you wanted to stay in New Jersey
because you like that you like not
knowing what's gonna happen you never
know it's an adventure man telling you
all those blown orders they always find
the body in the river okay right we we
call them floating off the Hudson how
come I can't flap and see if I can body
when I go across that ferry
especially with my kid in the [ __ ]
things that make a day no would you
remember that forever yeah I still
remember the dead body first body I ever
smelled really I still remember what
it's not life from ten feet away that
and it was heavy and these kids were
used to it they just kicked the piece of
plywood off him you can hear the Flies
like the heaviness oh my god it was like
[ __ ] and I was scared of course I
couldn't fold yeah
this is my introduction into a whole new
[ __ ] sect of kids I couldn't fold
like you want to see a dead body I'm
like come on and they're like come on
let's go when we were a kid you remember
you're terrified of everything but
you're captivated by it you gotta see it
I mean there's that thing that scares
the [ __ ] out of you but you gotta see
stuff you gotta you know you gotta take
those chances you know the fear was
there but it wasn't enough to stop you
from doing the [ __ ] he wanted to do I
love that time I wish I had that I wish
I had that fearlessness I remember when
I was walking with them that I had a
fear that they were gonna beat me up huh
like they were just gonna take me down
to Riverside Drive to beat me up it was
like Riverside Drive Riverside Drive
wasn't really finished at that time and
you just kept walking towards and there
was a fence there and the body was there
with clothes on it was a man yeah and
then it'd been there and that's the
first day I met him like I was talking
to Jerry Rocha and he's telling me that
he remembers going to Mexico when he
lived in Laredo go to Mexico every other
weekend with your grandpa you're gonna
head cut that there would be kids out
there and you'll play soccer with done
men and that you'd spend he'd spend the
whole day in Mexico like every two weeks
and they became friends at these kids
that's really rare that you go into
another neighborhood and the kids you
know we were playing yeah I'm SELEX you
know they they like you wanted they
wanted to impress me yeah you know on
88th Street with white people and I'm
like no no no no like the
superintendent's of the building like I
was a shame we had money yeah and we
went down there and that smell that
smell
yeah life it was [ __ ] just like I had
like it was like I had had a glass of
milk yeah I can feel everything coming
up to my throat but I had to keep
walking they kept walking well you
couldn't show it in front of them no cuz
then what I haven't look walking away
from they're going jesus [ __ ] christ
jesus [ __ ] right so back to my
daughter cross the [ __ ] sorry that's
all that's all I wanted so hard to see a
body floating by [ __ ]
mighty read my screams
join a cup of ice cream and then see no
bodies floating by hmm that's it like a
missing limb like a shark got him like
one of those [ __ ] to my bass you know
god knows what kind of fish developer
god yeah a [ __ ] guinea pig might [ __ ]
a snake it makes do you know it's an
Alex the river yeah what's up whatever's
underneath there man that's some scary
[ __ ] oh my god years ago they dug up the
Bronx River mm-hmm and what they found
was just cars yeah cars yeah mm stole I
don't know what I'm exaggerating but
they told ya 14 cars in the Bronx River
something something just fascinating
yeah
how many cars they found how many bodies
are in there that's the thing that's a
Lafayette [ __ ] the hotbed of the 50s
60s but that's everywhere I mean if you
think about when they were talking about
those remember those um remember those
two guys those three guys that went down
to Mississippi to register voters and
everything right yeah remember they
started draining those swamps he started
pulling and they would find bodies are
like that's not them that's not them
that's not them after like the fifth or
six body they're like wait a minute we
haven't even found the ones that we're
looking for who the [ __ ] are these guys
what kind of [ __ ] is going on in that
place you know and that's that's kind of
that's what's out there man you got to
be aware of that kind of thing and it's
some terrifying when you think about it
but it's also it's also incredibly
exciting man it makes for great stories
you know I was telling Lee that I went
over there Sunday yeah to watch the
Radio City Music where cats dog and I
passed out I put the 3d glasses on
uh-huh
when I saw the [ __ ] Santa Claus in
front of me and some reindeer and next
you know they were waking me up what
happened to you what was going on I just
was tired a [ __ ] though it was bad
55 years old yeah it's a six-hour flight
I was on the road before that three
weeks in a row you know you think you're
talking to people you do a podcast yeah
you have a family you have a lot of you
[ __ ] planner mentally yeah and I
guess I just said that but I also slept
on the plane there for two hours but
that's not a real fear and that's not a
real threat but if I don't fall asleep
on plan so we had a lead
on the way out we had to get up at 3:00
in the morning so train the [ __ ]
water you know you get to the airport it
was 5:00 we got to Newark at 2:00 we
drove to the hotel which three or four
thirty yeah we sat in the hotel till
6:30 and went out to dinner and then I
went back to the room and obviously you
can't fall back to sleep to first look
you're still on California time yeah so
I can fall asleep till [ __ ] 3:00 in
the [ __ ] morning and they're yelling
and screaming you know my wife goes to
bed at 8:30 every night so she could go
to bed at 11:00 over there I was falling
asleep at 3:00 and then they're walking
around at 6:30 we're ready to go so
that's what happened you know in a while
of running and it's a different
lifestyle I was livid I didn't rent the
car this I don't know where I'm going
I hate renting a car even though yeah
joy you're friendly you know what that
was 30 years ago
yeah I make a left turn I mean [ __ ] it's
connected here I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm going nothing now my
neighborhood you're in Schenectady bro I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm driving I
don't know nothing
so I'm going to death ah you know I had
every [ __ ] nationality on Monday name
it cuz I called six [ __ ] opens two
cabs that day just to move around the
city to one [ __ ] day it was wiped out
I get it
going on vacate there's people who could
go on vacation him and his people will
cut out to go on vacation I'm all those
people I'm not cut out to vacation so I
get you you don't know a vacation is to
me you wanna do an occasional vacation
as a beach son like I don't have to walk
a lot there's looking at Netflix and I
got an outdoor patio I have vitamin D
and pipe mm-hmm maybe a [ __ ] chapter
yeah that's a vacation to me I don't
want to see nothing I'm with my wife
it's not about me it's about that yeah I
went to the Metropolitan Museum of Art
which was fascinating this funk I saw
the Armenian uh the wing there means
your meaning genocide wing yeah they
have I got a medium wing that they had a
Chinese one here which is very
interesting
so my fascinator get out there yeah
that's a three-day pass but you need
three days to walk in there you do it
you
in there for three days you lose five
pounds yeah you stay away from the
pretzels from the [ __ ] hot dog by the
way of pretzels six dollars six dollars
to [ __ ] eat
carbon monoxide me and have some [ __ ]
foreigner touching with it how much was
when you were buying it
[ __ ] a dollar five cents everything
man six dollars for a pretzel done by
the ice skating rink
how much are cigarette my cigarettes my
mom was saying is they're cheap here no
idea how crazy is it there - you always
look I know well I think I know when I
was shooting Law & Order SVU
yeah which had it be 2008 yeah I shot
downtown mm-hmm and I went into a store
with a $20 bill I got a pack of
cigarettes in a Snapple and they gave me
back $3 and I [ __ ] my so you do the math
yeah I say this Schnapper was 250 -
maybe for 250 yeah yeah actually
cigarettes the [ __ ] is more my brother
comes out he takes back 10 cartons - he
takes back 10 cars now cuz it's a it's a
lot [ __ ] cheaper well you gotta buy
him here you got to do that you can't
you know you can't pass up a deal like
that I mean [ __ ] what is it is it is it
the base cost or is it all the [ __ ]
taxes were I pushing people out of the
office yeah well you know you watching a
good movies this year and [ __ ] lately
it's been a was it just like you know
what I thought Black Panther was
overrated I thought it was okay I didn't
love it that green book movie was all
right that Mark Wahlberg movie was just
like there's the luck war but the Mark
Wahlberg movie were they a dot where he
and Rose Byrne
adopt a couple of Mexican kids and it
was cute but they tried to be funny and
Wahlberg isn't funny he's even in a
funny movie he's the straight guy he
ain't the funny one you know so they
were going for these jokes that just
weren't gonna work and if you just think
they'll make it a drama boom you got a
good film there you know but don't try
to for me it's like when you start
trying to push the laugh and you try to
make them you know the connected [ __ ]
doesn't work man Creed - was was better
than the original
but that wasn't any good I mean I've
just been every three hours
I just wasn't impressed by it MARY
POPPINS is getting a horrible reviews
because it's it opened up at 4.7 million
now that's it
that's it because the New York Times
gonna die I just saw the preview isn't
it sort of like more kind to modern it
looks like an action movie almost to me
I don't know maybe it's in there doing a
lot for the other [ __ ] tortured for
point also you make that one that's
something also released it on [ __ ]
Wednesday yeah so they got a little
cocky everybody's busy with school woman
functions and Christmas parties you know
want to take a wait till Saturday well
there's also the fact that movies are
costing anywhere from twelve to sixteen
dollars per goin it's like that's a
family movie so you gotta pay for you
you got to pay for your two kids you got
to get them something drink
nobody wants to do that [ __ ] anymore
it's costing too much do you had
yourself movie pass no because movie
pasts tanked yeah it was getting to the
point where nothing nothing I wanted to
go see was available to me you know so
every once in a while I got a AMC where
you get three movies a week and I'll do
that from time to time but you know part
of the great thing about movie passes it
I could go to the [ __ ] revivals man I
could see I could see the classics at
the Egyptian or the Beverly or the the
arrow I love this town for that and I
can't do it anymore
so it's like plus Hank I don't [ __ ]
money for that so it's like I've really
been going back to you know watching old
[ __ ] on Netflix and Hulu and you know
like this coming week I'm gonna be at my
mom and dad's house I ain't gonna be
doing [ __ ] all I'm gonna be doing is
writing and taking my mom to the movies
and watching Netflix I'm gonna watch all
on articles I'm gonna watch
I'm gonna watch whatever that new
Michael Douglas Allen art Alan Arkin
thing is I'm gonna watch that I'm just
going to knock out as much [ __ ] as I can
do because you know come the new year I
got to get out there and start trying to
get some production work that's what I'm
trying to do you know get get behind the
camera do that do the extra work go out
on auditions and then go back to doing
stand-up at night I'm I'm pushing it
hard this year I'm not [ __ ] laying
down the whole purpose of it now is not
not to get a regular job not to do any
of that [ __ ] just pick up work wherever
I can do it and and keep pushing the
podcast because the podcast given thank
you in shape to work on a [ __ ] set by
you [ __ ] crazy Rick Rambis that's how
hard job for Dave and the lady a man
them what I mean a young man in him or
bus 24 years yes it don't stop on those
sets I look at those kids when I was
doing those Disney movies they wouldn't
get made like I was getting on your than
a dozen eyes work get made they
committed six weeks of their lives to
learn how to do real work you know they
lied to them with experience I didn't
agree to it I would never if that's my
son or daughter we listen I mean for a
second I don't mind you learning the
value of a dollar
I'm okay working like a meal but you
can't work for free no I'm not gonna
work for free but it's a yeah but what's
the alternative
I'm gonna go back to working a regular
job I hate that but but you you know as
well as I do that the $40 gigs aren't
out there anymore the $50 gig not not
like I see him every once in a while I
got to go to Lancaster for a hundred
sometimes seventy I might get a $60 gig
every once in a while but for the most
part that [ __ ] ain't out there like it
once was
you remember [ __ ] coyote Wednesday and
Saturday you were making anywhere
between 40 and 60 bucks on that then you
would pick up to two on a Tuesday or a
Thursday Casa latina was going on you
could do that you could you know get
like comic mmm-hmm had a [ __ ] side
will razón exactly and they all painted
instance 50 to $100 bill and I didn't
know how much money I you don't know
what you got to you lose here so when
the economy crashed since 2008 I got
straight off coat yeah but I was still
broke I couldn't figure out why because
all those little rooms that disappeared
yeah I could you know before you move to
Los Angeles people always tell you you
can't make money
and I'm gonna tell you something that's
a lie because I made a living
this is day one mm-hmm I did that one
room for Rudy for free the first time
yeah and then I was into a Rudy and the
brave bull yeah that was $40 to shows on
the weekend that's 80 then he had me
Thomas as you know that 400 sino so we
had all these alternatives I was
addicted to cocaine mm-hmm so all those
hundreds I didn't see how much they
value the house because I wasn't taking
money out of the house yeah you know the
same like when the check comes in for a
movie I would work with Rowe gonna have
to get my own work that's the house is
money yeah those little $50 Mexican
gangs or my bread and bought it we could
live on those dope I was pulling down a
buckle a corner a night yeah it wasn't
that The Longest Yard Jesus I was
getting 150 from those guys easy easy
the others getting 150 150 150 150 I
wouldn't make it ain't 900 a weekend 150
plus 15 from the store and man from the
store blessed are thou you know that
improv was giving you a little check
from time to time what's the last I was
here 25 $35 at the end of the week
you're making money but stand-up you're
not [ __ ] driving a [ __ ] Porsche but
if you act correctly you could rent a
room in a three-bedroom house for two
other comments smoke pot and [ __ ] eat
yeah and pay rent you know have a decent
car pay the insurance on it you could
keep your money low every move has to be
very calculated yeah what am I really
gonna get out of this move yeah you know
yes it would be nice oh if I do this
Rick Ramos has a room on Tuesday so that
I'll alleviate the gas price of me
driving down there there's all these
plans that you have to include in all
that [ __ ] you know I'm saying so but
going back to the the movies i watch
what's on the plane yeah the only time I
watch some movies well the plan
it's so amazing how when something comes
on in my house if I try to watch it now
the baby and a wife I miss 50% what's
going on
so the only time I can watch something
is on a plane and my two favorite movies
of the year were American made with Tom
Cruise yeah but Tom Cruise yeah you know
you know I would join Scientology for
Tom Cruise but like taking a meeting for
two hours just to hang out with Tom
Cruise
tell me about the Scientology [ __ ] yeah
fill me in AI tell you that there's
something about that guy that is
captivating hey you gonna watch I don't
give him leaning out of the copier oh
that's why they make 20 million in
[ __ ] film because you're gonna pay to
watch when he dies well from before we
get into this movie were talking about
this movie thing I was I called Rick
yesterday and I called I called anybody
who I've known the last 10 days who's a
mexican-american mm-hmm and I've
discussed yeah dis narcos series what
that primarily for two reasons the two
reasons were how good it was written and
how [ __ ] good Diego Luna is yeah and
primarily because yes I was fortunate
enough to watch the French Connection
and I was fortunate enough as a kid to
watch [ __ ] you know the valachi
papers' and and you know all those
movies of the 70d other child but
through all that time I always stay
loyal to Spanish television yeah and it
was something about Spanish actors that
count captivated me I became a comic I
went to prison whatever I became a dad I
have a podcast with me I talk to people
I get lost you get lost you lose
yourself then something happened on the
way the dance I watched the movie called
man on fire yeah and why it was denzel's
greatest performance I know you people
bought airing this no absolutely I saw
something in that movie that would made
that movie special was a Denzel and it
wasn't no disrespect to Jennifer Lopez's
husband Mark Anthony it was are those
Mexicans around him yeah those Spanish
actors around him including
was not a Mexican American actor
Giancarlo Giannini who was also well
he's that Italian actor from God he did
some great work in the 70s in Haiti but
he also did that movie with the second
Hannibal oh he played the copy novel I
thought all of them that his face his
character how he would smoke a cigarette
his mannerisms in in [ __ ] in [ __ ]
man on fire when he walks into the
hospital room mm-hmm and he this is my
favorite Hospital because it has this
bakery across the street yeah and he has
a childish smirk on his face after
Denzel gets shot and the lieutenant is
making the statement who's also a
brilliant actor yeah listen to his
Spanish how he performs it then the
Mexican white chick who's married to a
big-time director who played the
reporter yeah
they're sitting there taking notes and
he comes up from her either and squeezes
her ass and he says something to her and
he gets a childish smile that's what I
knew that guy was the real deal yeah
Denzel had his hands full in this movie
and he was opposite Christopher Walken
but work towards the end that guy on the
phone with him yeah was brilliant the
guy that he cut his arm off yeah I was
walking around with [ __ ] on he was
brilliant that guy got hit by a car yeah
that guy got beat up by deserve you
never tapped out yeah
then Denzel shot his arm off you showed
up to his brother man when he ran yeah
he was running with that little JP arm
and [ __ ] hysterical hysterical
phenomenal after the actors he handed
himself over to phenomenal Spanish
actors and I started thinking about how
and you never heard me come out with
this I'm sick and [ __ ] tired of the
[ __ ] Mexican American actor this
nation they shut down our throat anymore
they're boring that little clique they
have in Hollywood isn't boring they're
[ __ ] boring and it starts with James
Olmos I'm sorry to announce it he's the
king of war me he bores me to [ __ ]
death anymore especially after I saw all
these Mexican American actors yeah then
a [ __ ] their faces are rich with
culture
the [ __ ] fat chick he breaks down no
sir well be yeah good about say that
land he shouldn't have an Academy Award
for dealing opposite Denzel will his
shotgun go watch that see how good that
fat lady is you know we don't know
that's the thing we don't say no says
everybody eat the milk milk mickey
rourke what's in that maybe remembers
the lawyer I gots an Academy Award
winning movie all the way around that
never got recognized what about the girl
oh yeah just tremendous but I noticed
the Spanish athlete yeah so now we we we
fast-forward the [ __ ] 2016 or
whatever it also darkness comes out yeah
and I'm sitting there I'm captivated
this is a man that is worse than Tony
Soprano Tony Soprano the character made
you fall in love with him women love to
watch him even though he cheating on his
wife we had charisma he had charisma
don't be late Ron yeah Pablo Escobar
this guy that played Pablo Escobar hmm
was the he's the worst animal in the
world he cheats on his wife he shoots
people global blah me llamo Pablo let's
go by to get media and that make deals
for a living blah blah blah time the guy
opens up the side door and he goes
cheese and they walk up to the guy and
him in the beginning that's how he opens
up the movie he tells the guy what his
name is and what his wife's name is and
his mother just got out of the hospital
the guy is brilliant nobody's had a
[ __ ] peep about him
not a peep who is said about that
performance and I tell people all the
time you got a problem with not good if
you watch episode 9 and look out they
draw huh well he beats the guy out put
the stick and the guy spits in his face
and the spit goes into his nose and as
he's breathing the spit comes out of his
[ __ ] nose and the blood he's kind of
shaking here then he goes with her and
he says goodbye he turns his back and
he's covered with blood when he goes out
he has to say a word huh and he's
looking over everybody else's party and
[ __ ] suck and slum blow yeah he looks
on
sunset he takes a deep breath
and then the camera pans out and it
shows a pot plant taller than him by
itself blowing in the wind
what a beautiful directors eye yeah it
shows the camera pull back and then him
being him he looks to the [ __ ]
right-hand side and he notices the pop
plant and he doesn't get scared of it he
remembers his face is telling me oh
that's right he takes the pot plant he
pulls it to his face and he snips it
really hard and then he left said he
takes the butt off and he puts on the
top of his pocket he walks back into the
house he didn't say a word
no he didn't after I read what he was
thinking in his mind right there I knew
this guy's a [ __ ] powerhouse he did
two seasons then season three is the New
York Tolly Hotel great acting they ended
up but nobody has blown my socks off
it's like Diego Luna Diego Luna has
taken it to a different round now I grew
up on Spanish soap operas yeah which I
know one thing the acting is very timed
they had some [ __ ] teacher over there
in Cuba I heard that was better than
Stanislavski and they shut him down
ah I heard that he trained Spanish
castle and those people came up they
were the early Telemundo actors and they
were brilliant that their Spanish that
timing and when I started watching power
: to tame it shows all their show is a
shot on film to look like a movie yeah
but the birthplace is telenovelas date
and that's why some people like my wife
doesn't like them mmm my wife for what
my wife first of all if you're white
it's very what rough to watch Marcos
because you're reading sometime yeah you
can't get high you have to focus you
have to focus and watch it what we say
and then yeah they fill you in the white
guy speaks in English and fills in
but 60% of it is so I understand they
don't can't watch it but if you have not
watched marker narcos Mexico Caracol
entertainment Polacks le accrues from
which is brilliant they also put out
Jota Jota which is brilliant
the acting again is men's I'm what but
you could see that all these guys are
classically trained
Darko's this one the character of Rafa
and the character of Miguel Jose the
leader two of the best character
performances I've ever seen in my life
and I go down with my Marlon Brando to
the end yeah these guys knocked it out
of the park
the one guy plays a conservative mob
boss
he weighs 155 pounds but when he walks
in the room he's 280 yeah that's what I
got from Marcos and to the other guy
plays a psychopath who in reality is a
genius he's such a genius that he
figured out how to grow marijuana in the
desert he's figuring out how to take the
male plant away and pollination and he
figured out how to invent the weed
that's we call sensimilla that was his
gift to society he invented that he paid
for he was a geologist he dug and he
would dig and then throw grenades in and
then he finally throws the whole box of
grenades in one grenade and they stand
there in Austin water shoots out and
that was the beginning of the end you
know I mean the whole series he's nuts
nuts to the point of wow you know and
they're [ __ ] Mexican hillbillies but
this other kid I watched him I watched
the series three times yeah yeah I
watched it twice when it came out and
then I we taped him for the flight it's
five hours each way so I can watch five
episodes so I watched five on the way
there and the five on the way back and
then I looked them up and everything I
knew everything I saw was true his
mother died the car accident when he was
two and he was raised by his father was
a set designer of a theater
in Mexico City so he grew up in the
theater well he started and [ __ ]
novellas just like I read yeah just that
acting that precision that at the end he
thinks back to the conversation he I
would Kiki Camarena and the scene
between him and that Mexican kid that's
the thousand movies yeah was brilliant
his reactions his emotions what the
Mexican kid says to him
you [ __ ] up man Kiki Camarena son so
you [ __ ] up brilliant they were both
brilliant but this Diego Luna guy just
sensational just insatiable you know you
tell me why I watched three or four
episodes of the Mayans yeah it lost me
and guess what it was the same the same
yeah the father I don't see that guy
ever again it's the same [ __ ] storm
it's like it's the same faces and but it
doesn't have the balls to go as far I
don't know the Mayans from what I've
heard is just just they're not gonna
take it as far as it needs to go they're
not gonna be as as that's crazy with it
you know even the guys that they get for
the biker gang are a little bit more
clean-cut then yeah I want three or four
episodes that didn't grab me and I
talked back to what I'm telling you yeah
and on fire what I saw what I remember
when I was a kid I had a couple
babysitter's with my favorite babysitter
wasn't monkey though he might change
watching there was a cube with Chinese
well hello his dear friends with my
mother and her husband was a mojito
when I was five or six at night I would
go upstairs and they would watch all of
the novellas no instead mojito
but mojito was a burglar and he used to
take to us don't spark the ever give a
gap a spark plug yeah you know you have
to take like a file of all he could you
get the thickest one of those files and
he would make fake keys so I named while
we'd be watching novellas he would be
like
you go to a [ __ ] place to make a key
mm-hmm that whole thing they do at the
hardware store he would have those in
his living room he would just be making
copies and we wouldíve vanilla cookies
Holloway fizzled at the menara soda and
I could stay up till 2:00 in the morning
while he made keys he taught me how to
make them
I'd be sanding them down a little
grinder and [ __ ] hysterical but from
hanging out with him all those years I
watched novellas mhm and it's amazing
what your life be like I love television
and film yeah I listen I got all four
two movies does she have both
automatically playing for ten hours it's
dead for me it's dead like I got those
TV shows by new people you know I know I
do Greg thank do I thank them put me in
the show let me suck a black guy's dick
on camera ship you know very fortunate
thing you hear 20 years and you make
friends maybe people but I don't go out
like I used to let you're pissed I get
pissed I know I'm missing roles what I
get Bette you know what am I gonna do
you think that at one point no matter
what's going on that people nothing
nothing yeah that's how I'm okay with it
I'm okay with it I'm too busy anyway and
at the time I feel like it's an
inconvenience I got a wardrobe man would
do this for three days and so I have to
time I'm happy I want to do [ __ ] for
that one on no I get that I mean you get
to a point where it's like I don't want
to do the same [ __ ] get it squared in
the beginning it's like in the beginning
of stand-up you're like I don't give a
[ __ ] where I gotta go I'm gonna go do it
then then it comes to up I was like
[ __ ] Riverside they gotta pay me if
I'm gonna drive to Riverside they gotta
pay me and then it's like well [ __ ] take
it they got 40 bucks for me and maybe a
sandwich that's cool after you've been
doing it for a while now it's like come
up with a hundred come up with a [ __ ]
bill to make this worthwhile for this
drive so I can go in there do the
[ __ ] jokes and then come right back
you know but you start to lose
perspective on what you once were versus
what you need and those early days
you'll you'll bust your ass for nothing
I did because that's what you got to do
I did I did all that [ __ ] yeah okay I
did a lot of [ __ ] that I shouldn't
that look that you learned I realized
Jesus Christ they could have paid me $20
yeah they tried this at the door or they
did this they did that you know they cut
him but you you use it as experience you
use it as experience and you know what
you survive it you know because there
were a lot of times were they didn't pay
me [ __ ] and they were giving me free
drinks I'm gonna make him regret that
house I just give me the 40 bucks I'm
gonna drink $60 worth the [ __ ]
alcohol oh yeah well [ __ ] myself
comic and they give you free drinks and
you get $20 worth of coke yeah and you
get the free drinks you're as happy yeah
as a big as [ __ ] yeah and you tip the
bartender dollar bill so at least you
show me a little bit of class yeah
exactly
oh my god and you get [ __ ] up you
close those places yeah as a comic I
closed a thousand of those [ __ ] bars
you get the bartender at 20 you drink
all night for free shots shots for your
friends shot for your grandmother and
you're like shots brother one more come
on it's [ __ ] crazy yeah but those are
the those are the early days that's when
you were a kid and you yeah you get
[ __ ] up and I was right I wouldn't
drive I was at a sea I wouldn't drink a
drive I would drink up the comedy store
theater like boom well in between those
rooms it's tough for me I'm one of those
guys how old record drive have you ivory
sleeve and stop smoking drunk really I
can't see it no I mean you gotta you
gotta [ __ ] recognize these
limitations store I smoked a little bit
if somebody smoking in the back I'll go
back this only gives me a month or
something you're smoking a sanada but
it's really weird that no at night two
three hours before I don't know I don't
smoke no more I just get rid of once I
get home leave those once I get home for
the candy store yeah I feel bad for my
pipe I [ __ ] know that then no
giggling I make a [ __ ] baloney and
cheese sandwiches [ __ ] and I'm happy as
[ __ ] I said the emails I read my emails
yeah I torture people people will call
me like I said in the morning I wait
till 3:00 that time and I text them it's
just like a [ __ ] picture of me
playing baseball
or something like a banana so I just
have a listen for water why'd you call
me it's seven o'clock Sunday but now I
was just thinking about that people
gonna be home next week and everybody
always looks for recommendations I mean
I'm an old-school type of guy I don't
know nothing about nothing but I do know
some good movies I told you it's ugly
like before you tell us them on the list
are they do you have like emotional
connections to them these films because
like especially during this time like if
I felt like I was if I feel well I'll
watch something that maybe I've seen it
a bunch but it's like it brings me back
to a happier time or I really love the
actor like well you guys were saying
like or they like you're just like the
best movies or maybe a mix there are
moments when like you connect with
certain things and and movies movies
that have this weird kind of power over
you if you're a movie guy if you dig
movies there are moments when you can
talk there are moments when I'm hanging
out with somebody and we can just quote
something between each other we're
laughing our asses off I don't know if
you remember this but you were doing
grudge match and I was working some [ __ ]
job one of the many and I you called me
up and you said that you had met DeNiro
that day and he was sitting there and I
think you made him laugh or something he
laughed and you said it looked like
Midnight Run when he was what he was
like you know you know there's a better
class of people around here you know
probably all embezzlers to it they did
that laughs and instantly you and I were
connected at that moment because I
remember that scene and we were both
like little kids just laughing because
you're working with one of the greats
you're working with with a hero with
like I mean regardless of whatever
whatever the movies became or whatever
he's you know he did he was still Travis
Bickle he was still Jake LaMotta he was
still John you know Jack Walsh she was
still that guy you know and and movie
people have that connection so it's like
we're always gonna be able to do that
you know the movies that you're talking
about on your list
they stick with you for a reason because
you remember maybe it gave you balls or
then seeing what I saw wesley snipes for
the first time I think it was a spike
Lee movie but then I saw him in New Jack
and I was like this is a bad
[ __ ]
this guy's no joke and then you see the
level of class that's in Sugar Hill and
I haven't seen Sugar Hill in years well
Sugar Hill was on the list yes I forgot
Chevelle yeah
and I woke up mm-hmm the other day in
New York City yeah and it was cold we
weren't gonna do anything till 1:00 she
wanted to stay in play and Sugar Hill he
just thought oh I turned it on I
remember how disturbing it was to me
yeah
the black girl from Newsradio candy
alexander hit the alexander plays the
mother and coz the same way if she makes
her kids hold the belt or she shoots
arrow and then she overdoses of Jesus
there's a happy movie and then Wesley
Snipes was [ __ ] phenomenal yeah he was
phenomenal New Jack city well he was
phenomenal in this but opposite yeah was
a black young black african-american kid
his name was Leon right skinny kid ya
know what his name is he was phenomenal
and he did an episode of Miami Vice
where he plays a guy that was killing
hookers in Vietnam hmm well he never
stopped killing hookers drove all around
the world she said then he went to Miami
and he was killing hookers in Miami and
they had to arrest him but even in that
episode he was [ __ ] brilliant
yeah I never seen him in a while I saw
him and maybe three things
he was also know I'd like to say he was
too black Jesus in Madonna's video um
yeah that's yeah I think his name was
Leon no I don't think he was that guy
that was a different looking guy but
this guy that played his brother
Monsieur Gale who is a phenomenal
[ __ ] actor well you ask yourself what
happened to these people though you know
it's like did this up to the cracks was
the career not what it once was the
attitude getting get in the way did
drugs get in the way what the [ __ ]
happened to have for these people you
know with actors you never really know
because
that's a New York City movie mm-hmm and
in New York City you have so many things
going on yeah so what you have is okay
so you have like lleana ChaCha's and
what's he gonna created Miami Vice
Oh Michael Mann no no who was really go
the vanish Hector bar bomb oh my god
that's [ __ ] real prisons he what did
[ __ ] prison I remember that guy he
did um and he wrote a [ __ ] play with
angel eye oh oh oh yeah Cuba and the
they know Anthony you're convicted no no
I want you to look up he she wrote a
script and if we came a movie and then
they turned it into a play mm-hmm and De
Niro Ralph Macchio I was called Cuba and
this teddy bear Hugh buy this teddy bear
but the mean you know but no no with
that big Yelper they're running up in
there oh yeah Miguel piñero
okay so what you have to remember is in
New York City you have these little
stage companies yeah some of them are
polar regions yeah some of them are all
Spanish some of them are African
American acting little things that they
develop themselves they're nonprofit
they fund them themselves they live off
donations when they charge at the door
so on bottles of water they keep the
lights on they rehearse all nights a
week they teach acting classes and do
workshops these guys hustle at the same
time they write and they [ __ ] act you
know plus you have Broadway and you have
off-broadway yeah
and you have off off-broadway those guys
in New York disappeared and they come
back let's take for example war daughter
in the middle of Lourdes on there was a
fat Italian cop and they would always
tell him what to do in the room yeah and
he would always come back and go hey the
guns checked out and then he would
disappear well he disappeared for
[ __ ] 10 years then he came back as
Gigi in The Sopranos yeah he's the one
that was taking a [ __ ] on Thanksgiving
mm-hmm and died on the ball okay he
disappeared for ten years for a while we
were being managed by the same manager
yeah and I asked him what he was doing
he goes he does
Tunde theater he goes from one theater
to another to another to another so just
because you don't see those people know
it doesn't mean that's working in that
work what's that guy that you worked
with on a Longest Yard the pyro he was
huge he was huge
walter hill guy he played while you're
what David David will have a good guy
very decent great act the same thing but
that's a guy that boom so out there do a
play come back make a movie get paid
really well to go fund the stuff fools
we want to do he went to karate every
day I was a black belt you know at the
karate five days a week yet David
Patrick Jeffrey Patrick le that's right
I lost contact with him I left his agent
mm-hmm a call like a year and a half ago
you know the [ __ ] will call me back so
but he would he went to a couple my
shows in New York we stayed friends for
a while after that he sent me his music
and I lost his number we lost contact
and that happens it's it's weird but but
what you you know I saw him on a TV show
and he always told me you would never do
TV but this is what happens this is
where we're at now so a your app but
it's also like TV ain't what TV was TV
is respectable now and in fact you're
gonna find better stuff on TV whether
it's Hulu Netflix or Amazon Prime that
you can spin you're gonna see on network
that look a [ __ ] no addition etwork is
[ __ ] there's nothing on network right
now that you have a stitch there's too
much entertainment yeah we can't catch
up with what we got yeah so while I
should have slipping through our fingers
we tried different shows yeah we tried
different shows not everything's gonna
work for everybody no but we gettin so
much original programming that we're at
a point right now where it's too much
even the fat guy who stays home all day
was on disability right guys mystics on
the pound man oh yeah Doug tell you dog
this too much just too much you can't
sit here all day I can't catch up what
people ask me at chop people ask me all
the time was like are you watching
there's like a what am I gonna have time
for that I do your child what do I got
time for that you know and to dedicate
myself to a series and it's like and
sometimes you find yourself watching
something like The Walking Dead and I'm
like this isn't
good anymore I gotta get off this [ __ ]
because it's not you know for that one
moment of magic where it all comes
together and it makes sense and it's
great and I gotta sit through I got a
Schlag two [ __ ] three four episodes
you know and how we're a piece just to
get to that one moment I just watch I
can't stand it
a terrible show on Netflix and I gave it
three episodes what was it the one about
the Rizzuto's and Montreal oh I saw it
something like that um yeah terrible
just got all let's get to the movies
here let's do it so you asked about
emotion rounders rounders is a movie
with Matt Damon Ed Norton and the chick
that [ __ ] Harvey Weinstein a little
blonde they got cut out of Donnie Brasco
she's a Donnie Brasco and no one she
suck no dick that she came back strong
for [ __ ] around as they gave her up I
remember that uh [ __ ] she was a she
was number two she was Matt Damon's girl
Friel cube blonde yeah okay rounders is
about a guy that's trying to get his
life together it's very intelligent
off-the-charts intelligent you know so
around this league I think that's good
then there's the guy that plays what's
the really good actor that play at
Norton know called Malkovich or Tudor oh
the guy that plays the Jewish professor
that tells him about the yeshiva
oh it's Landau Martin Landau Harland oh
yeah he has one of them later Landau
Rosie they don't want to be a part of it
is she with his family disowned them and
[ __ ] tremendous speech he gives it's
about a poker player that's it it's just
a great poker player what's great about
that is it you get these stories that
are real oh my god Lenny Clarke was in
it oh yeah later you have read about
Malkovich was brilliant not which is
great I [ __ ] you keke keke keke like
last time he just played a [ __ ]
tremendous Russian so if you haven't
seen rounders it's time to run round his
uh Rick and I were talking about Sugar
Hill just a great movie about two
brothers who grew up in Oakland and uh
Harlem and it connected to the mob and
they sell heroin for the mob and great
actors to dad it was the black guy link
Williams
couple of Bogota a precocious gangster
yeah great actors in that movie if you
haven't seen it bullets over Broadway is
one of my [ __ ] favorite movies of all
time you're gonna laugh cry you got
chance commentary as the gangster who is
one of the best gangsters ever never
yeah top five and we stood great and
there was and over as that overanxious
actress who was like no stop stop again
I can't fat guy from [ __ ] yeah that
was Sean Penn's name and he got him into
that he played jelly only yeah don't
tell you don't tell your Batali's and
that I mean it is just a [ __ ] movie
that is and java to java tell his
girlfriend him that it was a jingle
plays jennifer Tilly each other for
telling give them the Oji Malla give her
the good stuff this is a brilliant film
yeah if you could find and hit me up on
Twitter it's crazy because they play the
only time I saw Simon no it's Woody
Allen it's Woody Allen Woody Allen the
only time that I've ever seen it what a
molestation charges yeah but after SUNY
yeah you know so he was already he was
already doing that [ __ ] yeah he was
movie was good
that was crazy Jeffrey's on you [ __ ]
I'm getting a young flower yangyang
juicy that see that's one of the great
things about la is like you can't find
that on video yang Ying juice yeah you
can find that everywhere I gotta check
on linkage ability being just by the
glass take it home and drink it I saw
that in a theater I saw that over at the
at the LACMA bullets over oh yeah they
show it they show like they got like a
Tuesday
one o'clock matinee thing $4 I would go
over that would just drop my forehead go
watch oh yeah they do they're doing eyes
wide shut sometime this week in the
shining I think they're doing some crazy
[ __ ] and I would go down there and I
worked in love it for [ __ ] dollars if
I now now it's like a huge theater if
that's a disappointment deliver the city
of students yeah you're supposed to be a
student but if you live here yeah so a
movie like that when you could see it on
the big screen why you know don't really
understand things it's always a great
to visualize and watch you can see how
much the directing has changed bullets
over Broadway was entertaining another
one that I haven't seen in years
that I [ __ ] love Matthew Broderick
and boxy blues having Christopher
Walken's great in it
Christopher Walken is so good knit that
the [ __ ] skinny Jewish kid that wants
to be a writer
yeah Epstein well glasses oh my god you
forgot you remember his name
Epstein is great with missing any
glasses just likely yeah wide throughout
the whole [ __ ] movie they can't tell
you carryin yeah yeah yeah it was always
something with him
no it's a Mississippi remember he
wouldn't eat he can't let early
Christopher Walken at the food wasn't
kosher yeah some [ __ ] he could need
Christopher Walken ripped it up or that
was Matthew Broderick that said perfect
yeah it was something day and he
couldn't eat it because of religious
purposes and all this [ __ ] if you have
the same Biloxi was a lot of fun I
remember seeing that me too it was great
87 86 that it was brilliant I saw had
the movie thing I'm like oh I won on a
date yeah make a mistake it was like
that [ __ ] joke Crispin why had years
ago they wasn't a date with a girl to
see Bridges of Madison County
you know how bad could it be it's a
clinician movie or sometime when it's
ending no this couldn't have a gun
[Laughter]
what's this this was a cohesive movie
how come he doesn't have a gun he's
taking on a camera what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] Clint you [ __ ] me I want my money
back oh yeah the whole bit about it I
[Music]
can't see without my [ __ ] glasses
won't blind
I'm also on them I'm also for some
reason in the mood to watch the regular
Apocalypse Now
the original before the before the Redux
yeah without that I mean I've been
having at the house on DVD via and it
gets the Redux I'm not in the mood for
it well if you got that if you got the
original it has both version right so
you just have to find the other you have
to find the other disc I'm not in the
mood for the read duck I hope I'm not
insulting anybody I'm just not in the
mood for the [ __ ] French and who else
to have dinner with and all that [ __ ] it
makes me uncomfortable believe it or not
I'm in the mood to watch golly that 98
what if you can find it there's video
it's all no it's on YouTube mm-hmm for
sure
okay the edited version is on YouTube
well it's gotta be on HBO plus well if
it's on HBO planted really well in our
HP yeah so I know for a fact if you look
at HBO movies like in those days real
did that one and the one about AIDS with
Rich Angels Angels in America no the one
before that with Richard Gere and
[ __ ] when he played the the
playwright and they told me he had the
hip and he donated his money
really I don't remember that one I
remember the one with Meryl Streep and I
remember the one Pacino we played great
Cohn Reich on that piece of [ __ ] so it
was like wow yeah
in the band played on yeah it's a
brilliant film yeah the cvetic I know
the movie I'm in the mother Phelim in
the mood to watch is the French
Connection you know as kids great you
know what Hackman is such a piece of
[ __ ] in that movie honey he's just such
a [ __ ] lowlife scumbag but it's like
you want him doing the job when he goes
in there and he when he goes into that
black bar and he starts calling people
[ __ ] and just like slapping people
around you're like this is my day apart
yeah he puts his hand on the bar yeah
he takes all the jar you sure there's no
drugs ain't nothing okay and he [ __ ]
tastes all the bar and he put some other
drink on the bar he takes all the pills
yeah then he makes a drink with them
doesn't he make something Erica yeah
yeah he makes him lead Rick hello
Popeye's here that was such a great
photo I remember the excitement of the
trailer
yeah as a child why cuz they used words
they said filmed in New York where it
happened to that was the trailer and the
trailer was the guy running up the
stairs and we shoot him in the back of
the shop shoots him in the back for some
reason I'm in the mood for the French
Connection from the last year and you
sit there and you go
it's gonna pop up on HBO like HBO has
been surprised about it Mike last week I
didn't feel too good yeah I just didn't
feel good i stalled on the after la
jolla the flu structure t flu oh yeah to
stave it off as [ __ ] yeah doctors give
you is it the four pills or the five
days I was seven to try yeah ten pills I
do that [ __ ] yeah so I went on that head
I just didn't feel like doing anything
mhm and it was like God [ __ ] showed
up 11 a.m. man on fire HBO East or
something like that I just wrote out
10:30 on I watched ESPN some football
scores and then watch man on fire and
laid that cuddled that's a gift from God
yeah so I just sit there at night some
like the other day boomerang was up I
still watched yes I didn't care uh you
know I taped the other night dude that
was on the other one that was [ __ ]
brilliant Harlem Nights yeah what I got
I got really drunk one night and this is
what I knew I was like I got to stop I
can't drink any my drink anymore but I
got drunk I watched Harlem Nights I
called a buddy in North Carolina I was
all [ __ ] up but I was laughing my ass
off at Della Reese and Redd Foxx and I'm
just sitting there screaming because
it's [ __ ] great when you watch what
really really is a great movie like shut
up [ __ ] you know she's a real sweet
like you shoulda shot in the foot all
that [ __ ] is brilliant yeah it's [ __ ]
great you're watching and it's like that
was Murphy when he was at this week you
remember when Murphy dropped there was
nothing like it Murphy made it comics
had to be kind of goofy and ugly Murphy
was handsome and the coolest
[ __ ] in the room Murphy wasn't
like any other comic Murphy every other
choices yeah Murphy did something that a
lot of people don't do that happen the
thing that could kill you in this town
of choices yeah
one bad choice we overlook it yeah two
or three bad choices you
Loosli mm-hmm you lose me you lose me
when you go for after a role for the
wrong reason as an actor I'm not talking
about as a comment does a comic you
don't lose you don't you don't want me I
go back on the road yeah you're a
dedicated actor you know you could just
make bad choices look at look at Jack
who net from sons of anarchy
you're making $750,000 an episode on
television you want to become a movie
star I get it yeah you know you can have
the biggest show on TV and nobody gives
a [ __ ] about you yeah they give a [ __ ]
about Tom Cruise 20 million a weekend in
the box office that's who they give a
[ __ ] about yeah when you try to push
somebody as a publicist they'll tell you
we don't want to talk to TV people Kevin
James a [ __ ] does yeah you know
something to us Tom Cruise you know
something to us Jamie Foxx
that's an interview that movie stars
yeah it's like being the lightweight
champion of the world and being the
heavyweight champion or who gets more
respect every way to have over a
champion of the world it's the same
thing so you're making seven hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in episode people
at home were going Joey what the [ __ ]
are you talking about
yes the last year of sons of anarchy
they shot 10 or 12 episodes he got that
$750,000 12 times okay so do the math
what he made the final season of sons of
anarchy so I understand you want to make
the jump to film we cannot lose that
income yeah once I get that rate that
high it can't go backwards do you only
way those backwards is if I fail who
completely and then try to come back and
now I got to rebuild it which if that's
a bad role I never will so instead of
him going to CAA who we jump ship with
and going eh listen this is what I want
to do I want a film career but let's
make right choices how let's make
choices
let's put me in an ensemble film first
where I have to share
opposite survival and I gotta go in
there and knock them dead this has been
my plan but at the same time I'm
developing something for your Netflix
for you not to lose any pocket change
I'm a Jew
I need that envelope every week you're a
nice guy but [ __ ] Papa needs that money
yeah you're going to work so what I
would have done is I before Sons of
Anarchy would have been done because at
the end of the day Jax teller
all I want to see him do is kill white
people who and [ __ ] white dirty women
that's all I want to see him do I don't
want to plant I don't want to see I
don't want to hear an English accent but
we could it was smart you and I could do
a remake of the saint a little one
the audience doesn't have to know it's
the same yeah I don't know the [ __ ]
Saint this give this guy his English
accent and make him a killer of
international [ __ ] spies like every
week he goes to a park bench and the
[ __ ] I sit next to him with a
sandwich I get up he reads the sandwich
he gets a note man Colin dumby calls the
number they tell him where he has to
kill the attache he goes to a warehouse
he picks up his weaponry
just like John just like it look there
turning it into a film yeah America
needed that more than average on which
is being turned into a TV show yeah so
John week three is coming out with a TV
show is also coming out yeah I would
have taken that kid and young $750,000
an episode shot ten quick episodes and
then would have agreed to scripts so
during the off season you're shooting
those movies and you're building your
movie career but you're not losing that
750 for ten weeks that's 750 at seven
million dollars for ten weeks work I
can't lose that I can't lose that like
if I'm making that type of money I can't
lose that yeah that's always got a
sustain no you're right but but think
about the mentality and the egos of the
people that are in this business here
you got a guy huge on TV and he goes off
and makes the legend of the city of Z or
well he did three Nate eighty three
three disasters Papillon he should have
had at one with Guy Ritchie which I
enjoyed what was the guy
enjoy because I'm an [ __ ] don't worry
Robin oh Jesus Christ
yeah yeah still no Camelot yes sir yeah
yes so here's a guy that you know and he
did three duds now he's coming out with
a new one but it's something sound both
oh okay and it's him with three other
guys I would read that script I would
pay somebody big money and go break that
script down to me so I leave here with
an Academy Award nominated even if it's
not that John ruff mm-hmm it's the
mentality you gotta go into that film
with and then that one comes another one
I rather wait for the fastball yeah then
try to hit a curveball
well you gotta pace yourself and you
gotta do the right thing that's what I'm
saying that's the thing this is why I am
how I am with my roadwork
I wait for fast balls and I will sit in
that pocket forever I just had an
opportunity arise yesterday and I was
gonna force a hand I almost caught
myself forcing him yeah
and last night I broke it down in my
hand I don't need to force the hand yeah
what am I gonna kill myself I got this
doesn't this go on
this just doesn't make sense cuz it
scares you this meat though I avoid
drama and I go flick your sisters say
yeah but you also said you're 55 now
you've been through it you know you've
seen you've seen your mistakes and
you've seen other people's absolutely I
that that's not something you would have
done years ago
no I learn in it from watching a ton of
people yeah I learned it's remember
everything changes yeah if I was 55 with
a girlfriend oh lordy I might be on a
bus across America late doing [ __ ]
you name it oh yeah
everything about cocaine like you wake
up like rotten [ __ ] narcos Foreman at
the mouth every morning you'll know what
life is do you wake up in you like a
sticky foam around your mouth you look
in the mirror while you're pissing and
it's white you know if you got diabetes
or the pills you ate the night before or
the chick you ain't harassed
two nights for go in the back of the
club and it tasted like [ __ ] but you
went with it anyway cuz you like you
jerk off and come on
but cheeks it's [ __ ] crazy yeah
waking up with fungal run your mouth
that's when you're on the road yeah
that's when you know Jesus Christ Jesus
I'm on the road jack so if that's these
are all different things yeah I wouldn't
think I'd still would control myself
I would had Thursday's to my rotation
and do the podcast round the bus why
[ __ ] around and take showers and hotels
stop for two nights stay in the hotel
put him on the other wing see that's the
walk so I think every time he has to eat
something has to leave a little walk
towards him telling us they follow this
from girl so it's two hours Stacey
civilization that time he gets there
he's walked two miles but that's what I
would do I can't do that if I had just a
wife mm-hmm
I could do Thursday Friday Saturday
maybe do three weeks a month but got
this little girl changes everything and
it changes everything and the next two
weeks you got no school nobody to watch
them see that's why so it's me and my
wife it's you and Terry and you guys are
doing the thing and it's got to get done
and if it's gotta get done you know so
because she doesn't care she doesn't
know who you are
no she doesn't care who I care about
podcasting doesn't know about the
weekend you know that's got like I tell
people I know you want to hang and you
think yeah here's the deal I got a
[ __ ] five yeah and she's gonna walk
into the church at a quarter after
twelve yeah and she's gonna run in that
living room and jump on top of me and
she doesn't care that I am it's a
[ __ ] game a picture let's go to the
park she wants her cartoon she wants the
park yeah what you really saw that she
give a [ __ ] about you and Columbus last
line you did two shows nothing that she
does know and that's when you see it
doesn't matter so I have to look at
things very selectively I gotta go to
places every other year mm-hmm I'd do
everything you know the podcast same
thing we're not here to do 18 different
podcast a week and I don't need to be in
your living room yeah 10 times the
[ __ ] week I don't need to be in you
enough I don't need to tweet all the
time I'll need to we all have our
and you know and it's just weird to when
you first come Tali you recorder back on
the 20-yard line
yeah that's exactly why I described it
try scoring a touchdown remember a
touchdowns easy on the 50-yard look that
those last 10 yards that's the danger
zone that's the red zone
you better get a guy that got that was a
thief in his previous life and nothing
leaves his hands or you gotta have a
tank to run that guy through you don't
have you're not well equipped you don't
have a running back no you don't have no
wide receivers and you block yourself
that's what you are when you first get
that fly and you're going up to number
one defense the lead which means you're
gonna get sacked three out of four
[ __ ] times you say hike for the whole
[ __ ] game you might throw the ball
twice you licked all the blue twice and
then you had ten years to that now you
move to the 20-yard line and you see the
field a little better but at the same
time you gotta keep doing your SATs it's
not just time no no it's it's you
working on your friend on the team you
don't want your Gersh don't want ya
Johnny Bananas don't worry don't worry
about that you just keep doing your sets
because now even Darby's on the 40-yard
line because of credit you're on the
40-yard line because a talent well it's
like I look at it and I look at it now
and it's like I know a lot of guys that
I started doing stand-up with that
aren't doing it they're really doing it
anymore
they'll do it from time to time and
they'll go up and I got a spot here and
I'll do this and I fell into that place
for a long time because you remember I
was just I was lost you know but now I'm
looking at things and I'm looking at
people who work regular jobs and none of
that shit's stable I got a friend of
mine I went to school with he left
Chicago went to fob Pittsburgh he can't
get a job on the regular because nobody
wants to hire a guy his age to be a
constant guy they want him to work Oh
work an assignment for three months
there's work everywhere this is a thing
called goob
so there's work everywhere yeah if the
guy
nobody doesn't get worth there's a big
misnomer in this country that I'm not
getting worked as I'm 50 I'm not getting
working as I'm 40 if you want a job
you'll get it you'll sell yourself in
the room once you start going into a
room with that attitude like what am I
gonna do a 55 no no I know be creative
well this is the thing when I read but
what I was saying was like I'm finally
at the age to play the parts that I've
always been I've always had that
mentality I've always been music I
listen to literature the films that I
love it I'm saying yeah theatrically a
lot not know I'm gonna have to figure
that out I'm gonna have to hit him up
again once new year comes at all have
never say no they used to send me out
and Allah Allah Courtney yeah Courtney
did um and I was I was getting callbacks
at the very least and then something
wouldn't happen
I could never close it you know like
they liked me but they didn't like me
enough and I used to think well you're
you're too fat to play a regular guy and
you're not bad enough to play a fat guy
for TV you know but but like just
[ __ ] excuses stop making excuses get
in there if you if you want to lean out
stop eating work out be that guy that
you need to be but I got a Carol is a
character yeah I can revisit character
doesn't matter how big you are
mm-hmm if I will stay at 400 pounds I
will I got 10 more roles and more piece
yeah you understand that I get you men
it's it's really weird
you're a fat guy you're gonna commit to
being a fat guy if you want to be Adam
Sandler's buddy mm-hmm I'm saying that
live Chris Farley go be it yeah but you
have to stay fat because once you lose
that weight mm-hmm there goes that well
nobody want what happened to the guy
who's gonna shake the stomach and make
funny faces
exactly well I need to get healthy uh
we'll call you yeah that's the problem
with that rumble in the jungle
yeah and most people who are fat one day
go wait a second James Gandolfini died
I'm taking the sleeve yeah I'm doing
this diet you know the reason why I'm
doing what I'm doing with Ralphie dying
yeah he was overworked no exercised no
rest for the wicked yeah smoking pot
with Pete
on the road bringing germs from all over
from different [ __ ] states mixing and
matching your real euro your bronchitis
turns into an ammonia yeah and it never
goes oh no it doesn't it does that you
can't control
they were saying so I saw the value of I
freeze I lift weights
jujitsu you know I told me yesterday we
went two days ago we went and did that
the cardio class together but I go did
you smell anything they don't say that's
not like Italian food I go that was five
days and no sweat
well I went home I smelt that rash guard
yeah any owners I smoked from my back I
whatever the garlic ball no my garlic
bread it's my I wasn't what had happened
you have no idea
that's five days of no sweat for Joey
Diaz my body's so used to sweating every
four yeah
five days a week I make myself sweat
yeah sweat I want to do the push-ups to
see the beads fall off my face that's
how you stay young that isn't the
Fountain of Youth
yeah when you're old it's not plastic
surgery run it's not [ __ ] to which
doctor eat it's not nothing no it's
moving you're over if you see it's two
days where we have some lifting maybe
two days a week of some walking yeah
maybe take two kickboxing classes and a
lot of sleep a lot of sleep and a lot of
water sleep it's just like crazy yeah I
bought two of these today I went to the
Wheatstone who drank two of these today
you know a lot of water I don't think I
drank a soda in New York I drank a
[ __ ] yoo-hoo but from my brother when
I got there sometimes I got a nose left
me drinks for the room man bananas you
my dad what the whole time I was the
deal got anything I you know that's the
way this way you you changed him you
remember Weight Watchers changed us it
changed the mentality and even though
I've gained a lot of weight back and I
haven't been as focused as I once was
that Weight Watchers pointing is still
in my head where it's like is that beer
really worth it that's not even if
that's not even my brand
why am I gonna do that [ __ ] I don't know
I'm always going with that and I close
doesn't be like 11 points it was five
points and I can live with that yeah I
always tell lead that
Weight Watchers is not a diet now it's a
lifestyle huh it'll take you two weeks
together just it's three weeks out or
the fourth week and then once you go and
they give you a medal and you're sitting
around other fat people and you hear
them wine yeah because the main thing
about Weight Watchers is going to the
meeting and seeing why you're fat you
learned why you're fat yeah all these
excuses you hear are the same ones you
tell people exactly well I went to a
party I had to drink wine no you did
there was a dick day you could have some
of that you couldn't suck that dick
burn calories and gotten yum-yum juice
but you didn't you know you learned you
look at people and discuss yeah you
remember you and I used to go to one
yeah we went together for probably six
months every Sunday then we going in and
out burn we had a system we'd split the
fry up and we'd have a single and it was
so so Deutz yeah but thought I told ya I
was filtering fifa's yeah points
remember that but there was a girl that
sat behind this that she went to Weight
Watchers for a social life and every
week she would sit behind this and gain
a pound the two and swear to God I mean
we swear to God that she didn't the
interaction points and that she ran
every day
and I would look at her in pity because
I would say to myself why do you keep
coming here yeah you have gained weight
every week and it would piss me off so
much that it made my challenge you
become a challenge against her yeah like
I'm gonna beat this [ __ ] because this
cannot go on I don't want to have a
sound like this person that's what
Weight Watchers sometimes you have to
see that though you have to I mean
that's why those meetings are important
because you see people's excuses that
were all yours
I travel I'm you know um I have family
in town I don't have the time
hired and we're tired you know I can't
there's a subway down on the corner from
Maya and you start looking like these
people gone I do not want to end up like
this yeah and you realize that it's not
a diet I'm just a life stuff yeah I went
the Gumbel play they gave you a cup of
rice I didn't touch - right that's nice
it was chicken and shrimp and sausage
and crab meat the [ __ ] gumbo yeah
that's a lifestyle change so I hate the
brisket sandwich oh I inhaled that thing
but there was fries I'm not surprised
do you understand that's a lot of cows
lifestyle change I drank a diet coke I
had no choice you can't go to a barbecue
joint no no water
you look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] I didn't
touch the sweet iced tea which I
would've gotten 12 years ago there's
just little adjustments mm-hmm little
adjustments it's not a diet but nobody
said that's why you're never gonna die
but that's the thing you were not used
to do that what we would do no I never I
never went on Marilyn was the one god
rest her soul that told me Weight
Watchers was the only diet
yeah because Marilyn had tried the one
where they oh she tried her system yes
she turned everything she said it was
garbage yeah and the Marilyn was the one
that one night we would have like a
two-hour drive and she wouldn't shut the
[ __ ] up and I remember that the biggest
diet she ever went on was weight loss
that she lost 80 pounds yeah she put it
back huh
I didn't hear a - later but she really
liked
she just started dropping down yeah I
can't just thought it go like Jesus
Marilyn and she wasn't walking she said
she would walk to the bottom of the hill
and back up the corner yeah I'm not even
exercising Joey I'm just eating she
found how to cheat the system yeah
there's a way that cheat the system you
could cheat it and drop tons away now
Todd she would she dropped 80 pounds oh
and that's the first thing I said I
called Rick when little Rick we got to
get our lives together we went in
January react it was like January 10 to
14th on the thing getting on that scale
I was 378 but I was 273 I think and I
had not been on a scale like I would see
a scale to avoid it I gotta leave to
look at the scale when I got on that
scale my fat
broke my fat little horrible I remember
the toughest thing was the soda that was
the first thing that went yeah
was she bought the the diet coke cold Oh
horrible
oh it broke my heart I was looking to
cheat well and then the breakfast
changed cuz you could have two pieces of
toast bacon in two eggs yeah so in those
days she'd make me an English muffin one
egg and a piece of ham half a piece of
ham with three points so I was basically
an Egg McMuffin for breakfast yeah that
was it but from those first three weeks
I realized that I could survive that's
what you learn first yeah what you eat
it you're gonna use lean 3/8 wing
muffins eat the one and forget about
yeah you go on and do your thing and
next thing you know you're like you know
what I ain't hungry they teach you some
great day he's just some great slow down
you're eating cuz I eat like a [ __ ]
brother like I wanna the chain yeah it's
it's it's it's over for me I'm just
shoveling in like a [ __ ] animal with
no respect for nothing but then drinking
more water but also once you get over
that hump it's easy but don't lose
perspective on it because that's what
happened to me I was like oh well I'll
eat this I can do this slowly a pound
here two pounds there that's bone and
that's what happens it's like so I'm
doing it tomorrow and it's gonna be it's
gonna be hard playing this mammalian
Sunday yeah I'm waiting son I kept 2005
war free yeah that's pretty good that's
pretty goddamn good yeah that isn't
happy you know my blood pressure is
stable I got on get headaches any neck I
used to 309 316 if I could tell if I did
something I get a headache you know if I
wrestled or something I don't get those
headaches sleep is important rest is
important you know like I said yesterday
I ran into something that I could have
turned into a money thing and I said you
know I'm gonna focus on what they offer
ya and take it take the free flight it's
business class for New York I looked it
up it's $2,400 they're gonna pay just
for the plane ticket I'm gonna go give
me a
attention they deserve and come back
Saturday yeah I was gonna do all the
agent would bother me we shouldn't make
this on it okay you know what why again
this is how you burn yourself out yeah
it's working smart and not when you're
beginning a comic you take whatever ya
as you move up you have to start saying
no and then you get into a different
level you really have to start saying
you know and picking and choosing and
going why I can do this disree for you
do this this week and looking and like I
said I incorporate everything I got
three movies left let's go all right
because of Diego Luna I love them into
mama tambien
that movie was I mean that movie was
powerful all the way all the way through
you know I haven't watched in a while
that's on my Christmas list threw me at
the end but I was like whoa waver what
the [ __ ] is going on here but once I
mean I was like wow this is just a great
film this is just a great film I dig
this film it's a it's him it's Gael
Garcia Bernal who have you've seen him
that guy's great too
yeah I think that's his partner yeah and
the theatre company about of Canada yeah
they do some really good work I like I
think that's quite on I think that's
Alfonso Cuaron there yeah both Mexicans
are making some great films they're
reviving a film industry that that has
been dead since the late 60s man when
they just started making cheap e cheap
schlocky kind of Mexican wrestler movies
or these really shitty drug dealer
movies they're coming up with some
really good [ __ ] because Mexico had a
[ __ ] great film industry back in the
40s into the 50s and then like anything
else the American the American market
just destroyed everything everything
every country in the world is primarily
American American movies almost no
country maybe Hong Kong had some good
[ __ ] from the 70s into the early 90s and
India still has a vibrant film Bollywood
yeah but France Germany Russia and all
of South America and Central America
none of these people really have film
industries because
people just want to see American films
and it's these shitty like you know
comic-book movies the Marvel's the DC
it's like this [ __ ] this bulldozer
that just destroys everything else
that's in its wake you know what are you
gonna do they got some good [ __ ] though
a little movie I want to watch that I
haven't seen in a long time
and you always got to watch one Brando
movie yeah and it's on the waterfront I
have not watched it in a while and it's
weird because we asked if there's a
connection emotionally I love that whisk
that's the number one more here that
connects with me because of the speech
he tells his brother which one in the
backseat of the car if you're a loser at
the time of your life and you listen to
that speech you feel uncomfortable for
eight minutes after that if you don't
have things right in your life yeah when
he looks at his brother he says he could
have been at somebody and he could have
been a contender
he could have been somebody yeah you you
thinking to yourself I want to be
somebody through here i am watching on
the waterfront on a Friday then o'clock
I'm sitting here with the Pittsburgh
Steelers Sheringham I'm 50 years old I'm
single I live in a basement I got a cat
named Momo who's missing a leg diabetes
complication and he comes on he plays
the ultimate loser yeah and you just
feel like a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and it
takes me back to excuse me the first
time I watched that and how I felt well
he said those words you know that's what
I'm talking about though there's that
it's that there sometimes when you're
watching something on the screen and
you're like you can't hide from the
truth you can't hide from how you have
[ __ ] your life up and you know there
are times I don't watch it something and
I'll see looser movies I've always been
attracted to lose or movies or guys you
know that that are looking for that one
last shot at redemption where they can
fix it you know when we were talking
about my show and we were talking about
how I'm overwhelmed by old man movies
and guys coming to the end of their
lives saying I
[ __ ] up how am I gonna fix it you know
the new eastwood movie is not great yes
sir
guess odd I saw it it's not great but
there are moments anywhere I'm like wow
that I get that guy that's my favorite
movie the old man and the gun I liked I
liked it I thought I asked you about I
really liked it good Danny Glover Danny
Glover is is he delivers his great
little performance [ __ ] Spacek
I've always loved always loved [ __ ]
Spacek you know she's always ever since
Coal Miner's Daughter you know cuz I saw
Coal Miner's Daughter before I saw
Carrie and she did with Mel Gibson the
river that's one of my favorite the
rivers yeah but she's beautiful blonde
hair you know she's [ __ ] gorgeous
she's just she's I was curious to see
how that Robert Redford I got a great
time with it but it's a it's an old man
movie you know it's like this is what
I've done with my life I've made
mistakes but I'm still I'm still
hustling I'm still fighting and it's
it's that's what's great about it I
loved it
to be Clint Eastwood's age and could do
a movie about a guy that age yeah that
has to smuggle mm-hmm to make ends meet
to pay for prescription yeah keep his
wife alive was on the [ __ ] machine I
don't know the plot of the movie I don't
know yeah that's a lot of it but it's
not also it's it's also the thrill that
he gets of being useful again and
because his life is going to [ __ ] it's
like my grandfather's 92 and every time
every time I go home I think to myself
this might very well be the last time I
see him that goes to my mind every time
and I think about it with my parents as
well I think it more with my mom than I
do with my dad but there's something
about living your life in saying I've
made some bad choices but I still have
an opportunity to make this [ __ ] right
and I want I want my mom at least to see
me be even just moderately successful
where she's now she's a mom she's gonna
[ __ ] worry about her little boy for
the rest of her life you know she's I'm
44 she's
67 66 67
she could either have 20 years she could
have you know two or three I don't know
what's gonna happen well but it did it
gets to me you know I don't have a
mother I know that isn't I think that
what successes as a parent and your kids
breathing if your kid has an apartment
in the answer job and he is she a handle
themselves and they're not on drugs and
they're not a bad situation you did a
good job as far as that went sir
yeah success doesn't mean any at least
not to me when I was 25 in 30 and 35 I
thought yeah it would be nice to have a
boat and two blondes and and show people
there's nothing to show yeah
it's forgiving yourself it's accepting
yourself is it's it's its success is
accepting yourself Gaia and not going to
sell drugs and I'm not going to suck a
dick and I'm not what if you one of
those women that [ __ ] thought of you
won't see anything you want an Academy
Award yeah did you really earn that
Academy or what were your talent well
yes because I [ __ ] have you opened up
the door mm-hmm
to get a position you know you still had
to deliver you still have to deliver
yeah and I think that sometimes success
the values people don't know the
pressure and the value of success and
once you get that you never say to
yourself what was really successful you
know success is me being healthy mm-hmm
me having a steady job me paying my
bills and me having healthy
relationships around me and the general
word there was happy yeah that success
that's he cruelest success
Demetrius does a kid that follows me on
Facebook he just went to Cuba anything
knows I had a good time and I go did you
look at their faces well Americans every
American should go to Cuba and look at
those people's faces and think about
what they complain that they need to do
the iPhone cracked or that you know
everybody we look at
things of our lives that have no value
and then we add so much on success on
showing people what we have what we
don't have and at the end there when
you're in a casket you're gonna realize
that success is number one being healthy
yeah and number two is being happy if
you're living in a shack on Sacramento
Street and you're reading and you're
figuring you gonna Y in your shower and
then you're figuring out how to make a
living if you have a smile on your face
when I come to visit you that success
yeah you know he says I whined to him
what he's well he goes into Tonka Keeley
Kiki Camarena Diego little girls can you
imagine
well that was poor I slept like a baby
yeah now that I'm rich I don't [ __ ]
sleep
you worried about too much you know you
always you know everybody whether it's
in comedy success in comedy or surviving
20 yes tell me you did Tommy for 20
years and you got nowhere I'm gonna look
at you and don't know you didn't you did
something for 20 years and nobody the
cards didn't go your way and don't give
up don't give up the cards didn't go
your way
not for right now but if you stay at
that table long enough and you keep your
chips love yeah you keep them low you
play them you know you keep them low and
you start [ __ ] calling and you keep
your rhythm ever winning rounders he
figured out the rhythm of the tape yeah
and he kept [ __ ] with them and
finally John Malkovich [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
read his tail luckily read his towel see
your opportunity you [ __ ] sees it
it's the same thing with poker this game
that we're playing is staying at the
table for the longest yeah how can I
stand the temp brother Louis am I gonna
go all-in on everything no you don't
lose earlier you come to me and go I got
a co-starring on ABC's grown men it's
over [ __ ] you and the commies Donald
look at you go I remember that one yeah
I'm sayin I'll see you in two years
our Fagin for a belly room spot our
friend did that remember we were talking
about that
I told ya I told Lee that the first day
I realized that our friend was going
downhill is when I said to her hey you
missed your spot at the mail room and
she goes ah why don't I go down there
for two hours for I like just said okay
yeah that's how easy that's how easy
this yeah she was getting 1,500 a gate
two gigs a weekend mm-hmm they were
living like doctors you know she would
show up for every spot one sadly she
told me she wasn't in the mood to go
down there and I knew right down in
there that you lost that thing yeah
because this even me there's times I do
a show in the main room and they pay me
a couple hundred I go back to the
original LP the bag of dicks for the
small 15 feels great when you go into
the main room and get paid and you bomb
and then you go to the original for the
same 15 yeah you eat a big a bag of
dicks you know it's crazy yeah I think
you're gonna get to this point lead
where it's like I got called up for a
gig in Lancaster Christmas party [ __ ]
worst all right
I Drive all the way out to Lancaster for
$100 50 50 miles out 50 miles back I eat
[ __ ] I get my money and whatever they
feed me and I'm driving back thinking to
myself maybe you ain't got it anymore
maybe it's done maybe maybe you took too
long off and you were just a [ __ ]
mess now and you can't do it well you
still got a spot at the light at the ice
house and go do the ice house and then
just redeem yourself a little bit I went
over to the ice house and I had a great
set and I was back in and that's all it
takes
it's like you know the bad sets the bad
sets are always gonna happen there's
gonna be moments when when you're not
getting where you're you can't pay them
to [ __ ] laugh at you there is nothing
that's gonna hit but at the end of the
day I know this is the only [ __ ]
thing that I have ever been really good
at that's it just talking you know what
I mean our percentages it is this game
is percentages and I used calmly I used
poker oh yeah I use whatever you love
you want to be a photographer you think
you name in the game is staying
the table for as long as you can and
every time you come to me and say I'm
doing up Pantheon for a movie I wrote
seven good luck you know everybody wants
to go all in yeah no ball until you're
ready you don't need to make that move
see what I've set your mouth he went to
going I don't care if you said that
table for eight and go I don't give you
some different rate hours and you go and
everybody will see you like are you ever
gonna put a bad egg no because I'm
waiting for the fastball yeah there's
nothing wrong with waiting for the
fastball that's right I'm not going
nowhere and I'm [ __ ] patient so you
wait for the fastball that's the thing
don't you you look for the opportunities
you've gotta you know build yourself you
know um I want to do production I know
what's gonna be [ __ ] hard but I want
to do it I want you know because I'm a
filmmaker in my head I'm a filmmaker I
don't know if I got a so I think I got a
story but I gotta write it and I gotta
learn how to make it and I've seen a lot
of guys out here doing that [ __ ] and I
think I'm better with all due respect to
them they had the balls to do it but now
it's you know you can only train for so
long then you got to step up to the
[ __ ] plate and show what you're about
and even if you fail at that so what you
still throw down they're not gonna know
until you try yeah that's the more the
[ __ ] story the last movie I'm
throwing out there is I respect for
Penny Marshall and it really is one of
my favorite movies in the world it's big
I think Tom Hanks was sensational
I think the scene when he's jumping up
and down the bed with the grown woman
yeah it's sensational I think the scene
at aureole facts when Haman and loggia
and Lopez Lopez no Scarface yeah that's
Lopez from Scarface it's Frank Lopez in
it yeah you know you know it's like it's
when you see grown people playing kids
oh my god it's usually the worst if you
have this big guys oh yeah my penny
March I mean listen legal around Tom
Hanks is a
the [ __ ] is [ __ ] but [ __ ] big
is so good the kid who plays his best
friend oh yeah it's good everybody in
there [ __ ]
Elizabeth Perkins I had such a crush on
sir it was gorgeous I loved her and she
had that having babies in them panini
the late great can baby Lovitz is in it
I mean who else yeah yeah that's a big
is it great movie so here's to grab your
pad smegal we're gone we roundest will
go with [ __ ] Sugar Hill will go with
[ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] I said well
it's over Broadway Biloxi blues
Apocalypse Now Gotti the 98 film
well-aged by HBO not the new one which
revolta now they are modeling a French
Connection e tu mama tambien on the
waterfront and [ __ ] big that's
down as [ __ ] TNC understand good
holiday view and man you're not gonna be
disappointed and I want to thank when I
went home I went to this restaurant call
us Aaron Tina he listens to the podcast
his name is Jocko listen they have
spaghetti with tiny meatballs yeah a
dish I couldn't even finish it was
[ __ ] tremendous he took care of us my
family he sliced his octopus slice
[ __ ] Lee your [ __ ] qua qua qua it's
very nice thing about let me tell you
something you you have no idea but if
you're in the North Bergen area by
Hudson County Park call with our
Sorrentino Tom tell Jack oh uncle Joey
sent you for the you gotta see the
arugula [ __ ] pizza with the cheese
over there where I kept looking away he
mixed me kept eating beets I'm like
Jesus Christ I had two caprese and in
front one time from the mozzarella like
those towel and it was clean Bobby we
understand the Queen that looks without
yet it was just a great [ __ ] tie Ric
Ramos always a pleasure saying it's a
thrill being here tell them to buy your
podcast watch this with very grand
that's better watch this it's me my
buddy Ibrahim we just look to get
release we put it out every Tuesday I
lie to find to iTunes him all right
brother
I want you guys to have a very merry
[ __ ] Christmas uh I mean this you
know where you guys are from Bob
willingness to clear the hoop he's
spooky to Bobby's sharing through to
tutor to the list goes [ __ ] on and on
you know I love you guys with all my
[ __ ] heart and I want you guys to
have a great [ __ ] holiday we'll be
back on Thursday morning ready to rock I
want to thank Rick Ramos I want to thank
the [ __ ] but most importantly I
want to thank and share you guys for the
love we shared this year together the
apps and the downs on the show and our
personal lives but we're all here every
[ __ ] week twice a [ __ ] week
and we're not givin up t [ __ ]
away you're supposed to be you know I
think I said it in our clothes when we
look at things I don't look at things
for what they are you look at things for
what they could be you know that's a
line we should all [ __ ] remember I
hope you have a happy [ __ ] holiday
with your family and have a great time
and may Santa bring you everything you
deserve from Lee myself and Rick Rambis
and all the other guests on the church
to see it I want to thank you guys on
the bottom of my heart
and to your families Merry Christmas and
we'll see you guys Thursday all right
don't forget I'm gonna be at the Oxnard
improv December 27th 28th and 29th
that's Thursday Friday Saturday you
listen as you're thinking what am I
gonna do with my Christmas money buy a
bag of dope and come down and see uncle
Joey smoked a couple of joints leo be
there
Eric Roach of the king of the [ __ ]
gay bars will be there I love this
[ __ ] line up it's Porcha Oxnard
improv Thursday Friday and Saturday once
again I like to talk about my sponsors
listen Bowl season is here and it's time
to get in on the action with my boogie
calm you want to start the year off
[ __ ] broke again like that MOOC in
the corner don't be that guy with no
root interest as your relatives and
friends sit around watching the games
like [ __ ] idiots eating [ __ ] onion
dip
not this year [ __ ]
if you're gonna watch a bowl game you're
making money and there's gonna be 41
bowl games to bet on including the
national championship on January 7th so
let me tell you some as far as I'm
concerned it really is the most
wonderful time of the year so make sure
you're ready with daily action by
signing up at my booking.com
today they pay fast when you win
ownership really cares about good
customer service and they offer the
craziest products when you bet where you
bet is just as important as what you're
betting on and if you want to make money
during both season you got to go with my
bookie trust them but you don't have to
take my word for it
check them out yourself okay they got
tremendous reviews staple you pay they
win everybody get makes [ __ ] money
it's that simple
but listen you know me I've been doing
business on my boogie for years so join
nine and my book you will offer you 15%
deposit bonus to make sure you got a
nice little bankroll for bowl season who
takes care you like uncle Joey
nobody [ __ ] you got abused promo code
Church when you deposit to activate the
offer that means if you put in a hundred
you got a yardstick and a half
that's 150 BAM just for using promo code
Church CH you are CH have my bookie you
play you win you get paid let me ask you
a question are you gonna start the 2019
single maybe it's not the cut of your
jib maybe it's not your bad breath maybe
it's not that [ __ ] wandering eye
maybe it's just every time a chicks up
she'd dick she smells you [ __ ] do you
ever think about that and that [ __ ]
got listen my [ __ ] ain't no cleaner
than yours until I discovered hello
tushy calm you're asking me Joey what's
helter she do I gotta go to a doctor
let's take a needle in my ass [ __ ] now
hello she's a portable bidet that you
[ __ ] install yourself in seven
minutes couple screws or hoes
BAM now you take your [ __ ] you sit there
like a doctor let the water sprinkle
your ass you look around the room and
you say to yourself who's better than me
I got five hours but at least my [ __ ]
smells [ __ ] clean
they come in all different shapes and
sizes and prices start at $69 you got a
60 day money back guarantee but listen
I've been sitting on my birthday for
three [ __ ] years between these shits
and the 300 pounds if I have them
busting my birthday you won't do none to
your bday let me tell you some that hos
has smoked some terrible [ __ ] things
and it hangs in there daily like a
[ __ ] soldier inhaling the [ __ ]
winds of debt that come out of my ass no
but because I have a hello toshiba day I
eliminate that odor from my [ __ ]
so it smells nice and clean what you do
is you keep a little French tile next to
you put some [ __ ] Irish Spring and
you stick it up your ass and you let the
water take that dead soap and all that
dead residue of God knows what you've
been eating lately you're on the keto
diet you got peanut juice and [ __ ]
leticia milk all over yourself you don't
need that hello
Russia calm a portable a day 69.95 they
start at go - hello - she calm right now
this is a bidet you like it matches your
patois BAM
put in the word muffler and get 10% off
your order you understand me
and listen it's never too late to use
hello - she has a [ __ ] Christmas
present if you gave me something to keep
my [ __ ] clean I'd give you a big
[ __ ] hug like he just got back from
Vietnam one of those anyway don't forget
Oxnard Thursday Friday Saturday and
hello - she and my people over at my
bookie who are [ __ ] sensational again
I want to wish his all a merry [ __ ]
Christmas and we'll worry about New
Year's next week let's just get over for
crock and Christmas the Korean might
send the rocket ship and we got nothing
you understand me and we're wasting time
let's just hope Santa makes it to your
house [ __ ] take that
[ __ ] mealy